[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where today we are doing our final homie
checkin of the year I don't want to do
this Nick we've done three we've done so
many already the whole point is the
checkin it's called the checkin you know
what this is why the older generation
thinks we're all [__] weak I think
we're soft and we're soft look I feel
like we did three check-ins in the past
two film sessions we've done we don't
need more than that I think we've done
enough check-ins have you checked in
enough just changed to a Nick check-in
episode we should do a Nick check I
think there's something wrong with Nick
Nick is displaying a little bit of toxic
masculinity here everybody raise your
hand if you're in favor of Nick checking
only what's going on Nick check did you
get a black belt it's not enough yeah
it's not you know what you know I would
love to get some sleep I haven't been
able to sleep recently why cuz the dog
keep keeping you these [__] that's
the main reason just the dogs yeah cuz
we there was a time where um just be
honest no seriously there's a time where
we let the dog sleep in the bed and then
Tiff is like we can't do this anymore
and I'm like okay and then they scratch
and they're barking at night and then
guess who got to check on the dogs to
tell them get in their face be like shut
the [__] up me just me why barking at
night there cuz they want to come to bed
they want to sleep with uh mama and papa
the door is closed and they're they're
scratching they're in their crates so
they have a little crate they have their
own little crate they have their own
little area and they
go like that but they got problems no my
dogs don't dude they're fine you
thinking about getting like those Shock
Callers that train them to not
bark it was it was a conversation cuz
you could wake up and you could just hit
the
button but apparently the shot color is
just like a vibration just to get them
like you know like hey uh it's not
inhumane because they're not human yeah
that's true you canot treat animals like
animals I will say this if you ever done
it before which I did it in the '90s to
like we had a dog and we did that the
dog was so surprised by it that it bar
bked about being shocked and then it
barked about being shocked and then it
barked about being shocked so it just
kept on it was Bas but um nightmare I
will say it's been getting better like
they're letting us sleep a little bit
longer you know which is nice but
whenever you wake up in the middle of
night sometimes you're just like you
really can't function throughout the day
it's really [__] hard and you're like
this is inconvenient this is bro it's
honestly sleep gets broken yeah it's
pretty rough and then I have to talk to
clients all day I have to you know do
this show and I'm like dude I am
I feel a rough life bro dude it's
[__] tough DK later a nightmare oh
it's a nightmare I got to talk all day
and talk about myself yeah I have to
push on a topic throw it to somebody
else I'm running out of ways to make
excuses about when you have I stutter
and I go what the [__] is your problem
since you have like other podcast that
you do if you're sitting here and you
kind of think of a really good joke do
you sometimes save it for the other one
oh yeah do you like hold back here so
you could do better on the one
like less staff and stuff so you're like
more of a priority I feel like I've seen
you do that you're like oh you're like
J
that this would be good for our MMA
podcast and that show grows and gross
and gross and
JK and then I do YF JK video on that
podcast yeah that'll be good that'll be
good written by Steve D please well how
we need some more views that would be
great balance with all of those
different things though mhm some
sometimes I go what the [__] am I doing
cuz I'm like am I doing too many
different things is this good content
well because startup which Demands a
totally different type of attention yeah
but then again too it's like my role on
it isn't that crazy either you know like
we'll do like I'll produce the show as
far as like the topics and all that
stuff but it doesn't take that long oh
okay yeah it it's not a hard hey hosting
a show is tough well I don't have to do
the hosting I just have the bones I just
just I make the structure and I give it
to Gil and then he does it oh so like uh
you're Ali ooper yeah I'm Ali ooper I'm
an ass sister wonderful yeah but um yeah
no it's good it's good well Gil I don't
know how he gets it done cuz sometimes
he shows up to here when we're not even
filming and he's like I'm here guys yeah
exactly well then and he doesn't show up
and the T we how we say come down he
goes I'll be there and then we're like
where's Gilbert and he's like I didn't I
was supposed to come and I want to shake
them dude I want to [__] Shake I'm
like how do you get things done with you
do you feel like you have enough time
time for Tiff amongst all of it that's a
conversation that we have where she goes
like hey like what's up man haven't had
no dick in like a two months what the
[__] and and then also for my mom too
like she'll be like I haven't had a son
in a year I trained my mom so I can see
her yeah so I can see her at least twice
a week and she got you know she has she
has osteoporosis and all that [__] so
we're trying to like you know tell her
to stop drinking milk I'd be telling her
she comes down to linhard a train yeah
she I see her twice a week so then um
she'll and then like Tiff and my mom
will have conversations about how they
don't see me enough and I'm like oh
great that's cool what do you say like
man a man can't [__] work around here
and earn for his family without these
[__] [__] not shutting the [__] up
sounds just like Nick I be talking like
that like you [__] be tripping that's
what I say let the man work cuz I feel
like as you get busier with stuff and I
see you do more stuff I also think damn
that's good news and bad news good news
cuz then he's finally able to pay bills
bad news is he can't go fishing yeah I
can't enjoy I can't spend my money he
can barely hang with he can barely hang
he can barely hang with T he can hang
with Tiff you said Nina he can better
hang with Tiff unless they're taking a
picture for the Christmas card yeah we
went to your 70 that was tight a moment
that was a moment in time that is cool U
yo somebody was cool why can't we do
that more but you know what though your
boy was [__] an Uber driver I was
driving like [__] 10 hours a day
going to Y cuz the whole [__] thing
is driving it's far y biggest [__] look
we we talk about like retrospect and
stuff like that I remember not too long
ago obviously like maybe a year or plus
ago you know there was a time where you
were looking to like build more clients
and like you reach certain goals and
like you know you were maybe slightly
less comfortable in terms of like doing
content because blah blah blah and now
you're over here in 2023 you got like
you know a whole new podcast show with
us like you're at lionhardt you just got
your black belt you got [__] two pugs
and and you're just like constantly so
busy now you know what I mean you
manifested ite yeah so like on the one
hand I still feel like a loser though
how do I fix that well maybe you should
like enter the competition once but
other than that you've done everything
that you set out to do and then some
like I feel like you had a very
tremendous year how do you feel about
that thanks man
um I think it's human nature to always
be like you didn't do [__] you got to do
better and you got to keep pushing so
like that's how I feel I feel like [__]
it I still don't even you should
celebrate a little
bit I feel like I do though I do like a
personal growth and like H goals thing
like when I actually look around the
room I'm like damn Nick did some real
[__] this year what part of you feels
like a loser like what what do you need
to what do you feel like you need to
connected to seeing his mom say that to
his dad all the
time oh [__] kind of kind of kind of
kind of um in a room full of winners
what do you need what do you need to do
what do you need to do to to not feel
like a loser
M yeah but I I think it's okay to feel
like that because I think it's part of
like the process of it all like the
bigger picture but I don't like hanging
out with losers so you better not be one
I'm trying I'm trying harder to not be
one don't like hanging out with losers
you know what I think recently when this
comes up is like December has been a
slower month for like clients in general
so you do kind of take your foot off the
gas a little bit on that and then you
focus time on everything else but it's
hard to well for me at least sometimes
it is like the noise of like you got to
[__] do more like while you have this
time off so I think those voices become
a little bit louder when you have
seasons of like a little bit more of
like a down slope which is fine it's
like the nature of the bid I breaks are
good too yeah no for sure but like I
think something I have to probably work
on is not talk like that you get a lot
of time management guilt yeah cuz now I
feel like I have a little more time and
I'm like what the [__] dude but I think
you do need to take that foot off the
gas and let your brain heal you know for
sure cuz sometimes you do rack your
brain a little too much but and it also
affects how nice you are when you
finally do get to spend time with Tiff
yeah yeah yeah you know but yeah I don't
know man I think thank you for those
kind words I appreciate that yeah man
it's pretty clear though I think we all
know you you're yeah I remember you're
like oh man the [__] pandemic and
like I don't got I got to go online and
teach people and [__] and I don't know
what to do yeah your gripes are
different yeah and then and Steve's like
man [__] Nick complains a lot your
gripes are from the opposite side of the
problem now which is good you know what
I
mean that's cool that's cool that's
always a good sign I just I just want to
make sure Steve doesn't make fun of me
that's all if he's making fun of you
that means he loves you the
mostes
[__] he say
anything talk some [__] make him feel
talk some [__] like you're a [__]
loser no you know what I will talk [__]
on though when you [__] he he's
like hey can I get the boys dresses and
then these [__] idiots who don't have
who don't have adult friends they don't
have adult friends right they have
friends not adult friends and I mean
this because they had they they don't
they've never had adults say like hey
what's your address in this time of the
year so I can send you a [__]
Christmas card all of our friends have
autism they don't do those kind of
things all your all okay I'll let you
say sh all your friends I'll tell you
the [__] all of your friends are young
kids that you raised to be your
editors and then you that's why you
don't get Christmas cards cuz they're
[__] a bunch of kids they don't have
they don't have I get Christmas cards
but I have four [__] addresses so
depending on where I am for the holidays
I needed him to send it to the right
address yeah but dude this is so so it's
what you said it's what you said that
the
kicker so that though my favorite thing
Joe responds like cuz Nick's like hey
can I get your addresses and Joe's like
hey dude if you guys are if you're going
to send like perishables or something
like send it to this address I did not
say you said that as a joke no no my
joke was my joke was saying but my joke
was like Joe be like hey guys if you're
going to send me live live animals send
it to this address I didn't say
perishable I no you said you said
packages but yeah yeah I packages but
it's funny as
[__] underdeveloped [__] adults if
you're get S me P Simmons man I got to
know where it's going cuz I got to be
there how fresh are the P Simmons
they how fresh is the Pento
dudeo and I love talking to tip about
this because she was dying about it she
just sent she was just sending an
innocent Christmas card out this whole
drama in our [__] she was giving me
[__] cuz she was like can you get the
addresses from the guys and I was like
Yay I'll get it from them but I'm like I
don't want to bother them blah she's
like [__] get their addresses and I
was like okay you I don't have
conventional adult friends either that
do that normally so that's what I'm
saying all my friends autism cards my
only Christmas cards on the fridge is
his and Mitchell in me and Mitchell in
bro yeah wait you already sent it out I
need to check my mail what the [__] dude
oh I got it I just got home last night
check probably threw the trash dude took
your mail your mail man hates you I just
left last night no two nights ago G
probably threw that [__] in the trash n
it probably be on our F you just like
you were at the Holiday party I wasn't
at oh then maybe two days
ago so what's let's check in with you
Anthony Lee yeah yeah I'm hosting the
promps I'm just the host so what about
you I thought it was all Nick yeah Nick
I can't fill up eight more
[Laughter]
minutes what what are you supposed eight
minutes of deflecting maybe what are you
supposed to do on a wellness check
you're just supposed to say I'm well
here's the thing the the reason why it
even started the very first time was
because you know there was moments of
conflict and we were just like yo we
should check in with each other because
we don't know sometimes when somebody's
going through some tough [__] that's
true you don't know until you ask we we
for [__] we did four checkings in Q4 bro
I think that's good hey but the point is
that you don't know until like every
time until you ask the point is we're
trying to like make it cooler for dudes
to talk about their [__] yeah I I'll
tell you something I don't got no sad
[__] cuz my life is [__] sick but uh
hell yeah [__] get too relatable I'll
give you a get my dick sucked every day
you don't need to
share I'll tell you I'll tell you
appreciation thing about you guys is
that like I mean you guys already know
this where um there you know a like two
years ago it was a it was a Rocky Point
in JK right like like with uh lockdown
we weren't filming every day we stopped
posting every day I want to say like
that was probably when we got the
biggest hit is when when you stop
posting like three times a day like like
this news channel the the routine people
will probably be like going somewhere
else to get their fix right we were
posting like on every other day or or
whatever it was but that's when we saw
the biggest drop and then after that a
lot of people didn't want to film and
like keep this going a lot of people
were scared they're like oh well I don't
know [__] you know Co you guys you
guys aren't being safe and [__] and then
like I remember we did me and Bart did
one episode with a [__]
mannequin and the cuz nobody wanted to
[__] come a Manakin and the deal you
would you had Co so you
had I'm a rider I would have been here
you guys asked me to come but I was
going to go to Hawaii so I was like I
can't risk it my boys I mean but but
yeah I just remember it being like damn
dude I thought we really had some ride
or dies that would just come through and
then they didn't and then I was like
really questioning I had Co yeah
whatever dude actually had it but by the
way it was [__] [__] but I still had it
and I didn't want to get anybody Co so
it wasy you actually had Co versus the
people that were like oh I don't know
about coming because I'm going to go see
some family you know and then uh not
reasonable at all what you said it was
part it wasn't even a part of it at the
time okay they asked me dude I was going
to I even said that I would come but I
didn't want to get anybody sick that's
what I said but the point is I think
that's when I was like oh [__] you know
this is different and then and it was so
hard during that time to get guests to
get people to want to be here and I was
like this is the first time I hear so
much [__] complaining about coming
together to talk we're actually just
coming together to have fun and talk
right and then so I was like is this
really a hard difficult thing to do I
don't don't get it but then when you
guys started coming in and we were
starting to create this group one by one
it was like giving me this like Joy of
oh you want to be here and then the
energy of people wanting to be here 100%
is such a different vibe than like when
some people are like oh I feel like I
have to be here and I'm like no one's
forcing you but that I think that was a
different kind of um kind of like a
Awakening for me to just feel this group
together and being like oh [__] this is
different this is this is like I can see
it happening again but differently well
also I will say this too as an
experience to member um it's weird it's
weird when everyone like when it's like
5:00 whatever and people
like is it time to go it's almost like I
don't want to go no like I don't want to
go even though you're leaving first
again I am leaving first real soon but I
don't want to like I like it here that's
the thing it's nice to have everyone
here want to be here me and Bart were
like beg people to like want to be
excited about working on projects and
I'm like how are we going to have a
entertainment company when hella people
are just like I don't want to do it no
more and that's when you realize the
mannequins don't talk bad yeah but then
the difference was with you guys and all
also the difference is you guys are all
leaders in your own business right and
it's a it's completely different when
you're working with people that are just
like initiators like you have an idea
you just have Ryan do it and like you
know it's just everyone's
like everyone's like hey sometimes you
need leaders sometimes you need
followers that's part of being a good
leader no one skill sets right yeah
Anthony has ideas Ryan carries it out
the David so the ideas man but then Ryan
works for coffees he works this office
is a true Testament of like when
everyone was like oh this place sucks we
should change it no one's [__] doing
a dam damn thing and then like Ryan's
like yo I got this over the fall and I'm
like [__] dude this is this is what it
can be when everybody like goes full
force and we're doing it full force part
time so I'm like imagine what can happen
if we do spend just a little bit more
time and energy into it and then it's
that's very exciting and that's what
makes me grateful to like like keep this
going and it's it's it's it's just a
really awesome experience to to share
that with you guys did brother yeah yeah
100% that's cool
that's cooler of course yeah no what
about you Anthony what do you let's
bring it back to Nick on our last minute
so you got any problems anything you
want to complain about yeah um you said
earlier today and this made me a little
sad when you came in you said this is
the best sweater that I own do you need
clothes how you reg that's [__]
incredible this is a conversation that I
have with my wife all the time with Tiff
where she makes fun of me she goes I'm
I'm sick and tired of you coming into my
room where we're about to go out to go
out somewhere and asking me is this
shirt too small does this shirt look
stupid do I look dumb that's what I ask
her when I see her so yeah I do need
some new clothes dud new clothes then
yeah yeah I do need to get some new
clothes I need Anthony Lee or Ryan to
style me dude can we go to the mall
sometime he would never go to mall I
think that would be fun dude we just
play dress up with Nick oh my God that'd
be a JK Advent right there yeah it's
like a it's like queer eyee but like ey
even he another update I started a
Korean skincare routine and I like it a
lot
dude we don't have to share everything
dude I think we're
goodin us
on check I started a new uh sadine
sadine
toothpaste